hi this is the works of basically about
generating images and texts and we will
go through it so one part of the first
part of the works up it's going to be
about the image generation and the
second part it will be given on the text
generation so I am Dimitra from for the
first part and I work as a data
scientist in a smell I am actually
missing learning architecture and yeah I
would like to introduce students who did
their internship at tsunami and Turku
working and okay these works have
started as an idea to focus more on
named a generation and go through that
but since generative modeling it's a
relatively new topic there we we decided
having write a scenario and [ __ ] that
it's a very nice idea also to give some
workshop on different types of models
for different types of data images and
text they are quite different
so yeah the pixels in an image they are
conducive continuous data while we take
States the words there they are discrete
data images we see a special
dependencies there while in text we see
time and sequences and others and also
images are not too sensitive to local
changes while a text it is as a result
the models that they are used therefore
generation of images and text they are
completely different and we will give
you an idea about it now so who of you
how many of you are familiar with
generative models
hey how many of you have used the
generative models okay it's fine so I
expect them that the basics of it some
of you know it what a generative model
tries to do it's not to predict some
target values as a discriminative models
they do investing learning but it tries
to learn the data distribution so for
example it will have a set of images
what he tries to do it's to understand
what is the distribution of those images
and it does that so that it can mimic
that the distribution and and start
sampling from that distribution in order
to generate new images in that case and
what are the requirements that we have
for those new observations new data
points that we want to help they have to
look similar with the original
observations in the sense that they come
from the same distribution but also are
quite different so that they are still
original and they give some new
information so they don't look exactly
as what we have seen before we will see
those through the work substance some of
you also most half of the room is now is
about the generative modeling I won't go
through an example to save some time and
one what I'm going to present for image
the generation it's I will focus on
variational auto-encoders which is based
on auto-encoders it extends that idea
how many of you know about
auto-encoders okay and how many of you
have used to encoders okay so I will
explain it then I will have brief brief
for those of you who have who know that
so what it's a little coder
it's a network that takes a simple that
has the same input and output network
and so why is this interesting
basically it's quite interesting because
of its architecture so basically we have
layers that they take the input and they
decrease the number of units as the
number of layers increases till they
reach a layer with a small number of
units the smallest number of units which
is called bottleneck and that bottleneck
after that bottleneck then they start
increases increasing their number of
units till they reconstruct basically
the input that they had and it's the
first part of the network before the
node the bottleneck it's called encoder
and the second part is called decoder
and what the bottleneck does it's
basically gives a code a compressed
representation of the input that we give
here we see an example for example with
some diseases yeah pretty trivial based
on for image degeneration and - what are
the applications of a the dimensionality
reduction for example if you have a code
two dimensions then someone can
visualize the data and start
understanding that they tend to observe
it because high dimensional data gets
the motive visualize it and get some
insights from them itself visualization
anomaly detection so for example someone
can say if the one who learned your data
distribution and and some anomaly comes
if you expect that it has higher
distance than the rest of your data and
this is better to be done on a low
dimensional space because in high
dimensional spaces
distances can be misleading it's called
the curse of dimensionality basically
muscle learning and this is something
that could have been used for image
third generation but it's not a very
recent there but because what they try
to do or what other coders try to do
it's just to reconstruct the input very
well so they're lost function it's just
to minimize the distance between the
reconstructed input and the original
input they're here it's just the gap
just buta mean square error or it can be
anything and the other result for
example if we want to see how this the
representation the code looks like if we
do it for a multiple for the full data
set with digits what we see it's
basically this type of visualization
here it's a color it's one digital
yellows one and so on and if someone
wants to generate new images from from
that from that low dimensional
representation which has to do it's a
two sample space and just try to pass
that sampling through the decoder and to
get a generation of images but this does
not work well so if someone tries to
sample an image like
like here in the middle we see that
there is a gap so how this how this
sample can has to be reconstructed it's
not very clear because of the gaps and
also what we see it's that there are
areas and Latin space representation
that they are highly dense and to other
parts of the area that they are much
less dense and as a result how to sample
also this different density areas it's
not very clear so if someone wants to
use auto-encoders as they are for in
construction it doesn't work because of
those issues and to those issues there
are discontinuity of the living space
the different spread of data points it
can be also an indication of overfitting
what we can say in machine learning for
autoencoders and this is the issues that
the variational auto encoder is really
is going to work against and so who of
you how many of you know about
variational mental coders already okay
so I will explain if you have questions
about variational mental coders feel
free also to ask during the presentation
so I will give an explanation then we
will go to the notebook what is the
difference between how they try to solve
this overfitting issue Center this what
we saw this discontinuance of the Latin
space and these problems it's by instead
of mapping one point to one input two
observation to one point in the Latin
space they map it to a distribution
to a normal distribution basically
around a particular point so the encoder
instead of returning back via other to
the Latin space one some coordinates for
one point it returns a mean and a
standard deviation value for that
particular input point in this way what
it's being ensured its that it's not
just one point that when it when it's
being decoded it will it will generate
an image similar to the original one
but it's a neighborhood of of points
that they can generate similar images so
the issues of discontinuity if they are
going to be resolved this way and
autoencoder
this type of audio recorder it's very
likely that we'll return well-formed
images even if from the regions where we
didn't have any points originally so how
the network structure it's going to look
like it's a very similar with the
provision but now we have a kind of a
probabilistic view of the encoder mostly
and the network as well so the encoder
for its point will return the mean and
the standard deviation of particular
distribution we want that distribution
to be very close also to the standard
normal distribution which means
basically distribution with mean 0 and
standard deviation 1 and from those
[Music]
distributions in order to have a little
space representation we need to sample
this is a very normal way to sample from
the mean the standard deviation and some
random
represented by excellent and then we can
have a we can pass our sample through
the decoder which is exactly the same as
the decoder in the normal auto encoder
it can be anything I have also there
some normal Network units it can be
anything it can be convolutional layers
it can and also then we are going to
have a convolutional laser and just a
small idea of how the loss function
looks in the variation little coder we
have again the reconstruction lost part
were basically the decoder tries and the
free Network they try they try to
reconstruct their input as best as they
can so there it's basically the local
likelihood the negative look likelihood
of our data given some encoding I roll
it yeah you can see it's very similar as
the reconstruction error of the normal
encoder it's expressed in a
probabilistic way because it's a
probabilistic structure variation along
decoders and there is then a second part
in the loss function which is like which
is no detail as los que el it's cool
back library
divergence basically between the
distribution that the encoder returns
back for a particular input and the
standard normal distribution so what
here which are they try to do its to
penalize any distribution that is
returned back from the encoder that it's
not close to the standard normal
distribution so this access
regularization factor to variational
auto-encoders and it helped them
generalize very well and also have a
very nice structure in the Latin space
because we all know normal distributions
that
quite smooth so if we want for the same
example to see how the same
representation would look like we see
now that yeah indeed the space doesn't
have gaps and to all the points they are
quite similarly distributed in the space
so someone can just sample that space a
random point in that locking space and
to generate images and those images will
who will be well formed with high
probability based we will see this in
our workshop one thing that I would like
to mention last before we go to our
hands on assessing it's that variational
anti coders despite the fact that they
have these nice properties they tends to
generate blurry images so what people
usually do in order if they are
interested also in the decoder part that
code to conduct the results they combine
it with adversarial neural networks
generative adversarial neural networks
and the way so that basically they get
some help in a training of it accord and
to the way that this works its they have
say this is the part of variational Auto
I didn't explain guns are you do you
know how guns work how many of you do
you not do they know how cancer okay I
will explain them so the way that guns
work its they have a generator that
takes random samples take random samples
some noise and tries to produce some
images fake images and they have a
second part like a discriminator which
tries to understand if those images are
that they have been generated by the
generator
or fake or real so it's yeah gun so they
are known for having very sharp image
generation but they are very difficult
to be trained because they are quite as
stable so a combination of the two it
and also they don't have Latin
space-like autoencoders or variational
decoders a low dimensional
representation that can help us perform
operations there we will see what we can
to do with these Latins face also in the
function session so that what people are
doing is they are using the variational
auto encoder part so they have the
encoder as we explained the decoder of
operational and decoder becomes the
generator for the guns
and so then the gun and network instead
of taking some random samples and try
and having the discriminator to
understand if those samples of the
generated images are fake or real
it takes samples from the variational
not a coder so the output of variation
elect autoencoder it's it's what the
discriminator tries to discriminate
between fake and image as a result this
process helps the decoder of variational
auto encoder to become smarter and
smarter as the discriminator of ganz
becomes smarter we won't have time to go
through this part in this workshop but I
have a notebook for you so that you can
play with it if you want so let's go to
the hands-on session and please go to
this address
it's a github account that has some
notebooks and for both parts for both
the image and text generation and yeah
we can
did you go there how many of you have
gone there just a beat
you see the
you should be looking something like
that is how the structure looks like
it's there is a readme file with
references for the text generation part
so sonali and kuhn we'll explain that
later now we go to image generation part
and then we can see the two notebooks
let's go - yeah here on the first part
you can see the slides that I present it
with references there if you are
interested in the images or or
combinations of vis with guns and so we
can go to a notebook from there the
first one and we see how it looks like
and we press the button opening colab so
that we will work with it in google
collaboratory
have you gone there how many of you are
on they have money stop another note
coca-cola okay so we can start welcome
we are going to work it's about
basically image degeneration on a
fashion dataset so it's a dataset that
has been released by the ladder research
in order to have more a very easy data
set to work with in terms of processing
and training neural networks very fast
to train a neural networks there and
they are not as boring as out single
digits and so on and what we need to do
its to make sure basically also that our
run time it's set to GPU so if you go to
run time change run time type and go
make sure that it's the GPU in safe that
will help us having more time and yeah
we are using also caters with tensor
flow in the backend and carries
probability so we can start running our
notebook we can start basically and
installing to our requirements it was
not really connected what do we really
need as requirements for that it's a
tense reflow to pursue a collab
recurrently runs with 10 300 won and
this is but it's going to change soon
and the probabilistic reasoning for
potential flow so it's a year should be
downloading your data
is this okay necklace it's text for
requirements etc we can load our modules
which is basically typical modules if
someone wants to have such a notebook I
would another thing I would like to
mention is that there are two api's if
you are not familiar with the carriers
to work with the one it's the sequential
KPI and the other one it's the
functional KPI we are going to use the
sequential one because it's simple as
simple in a sense that it allows you to
stack layers one next to the other very
quickly the functional API allows you to
give it's more flexible in the sense
that it allows you to give input of one
layer to other layers that they are not
the next one in stock necessarily but we
am not we're not going to do that with
we will have a simple variation elantra
coder here until we self chasm notebook
aesthetics you can find also some
description of the fashion dataset it
has 60,000 training examples into the
10,000 test examples and let's load the
image the files
and let's visualize some images using
matplotlib so we can see how they look
like we say some sneakers some t-shirts
some dresses yeah some uncle boots some
sandals they're and what we try we will
try to do basically to learn the
distribution of those images and
generate new ones and we start with our
coding here so what we need to define it
like normal neural network things like
bad size we still need to have budgets
to train the network's they mentioned
are the dimensions of the data set etc
so and then we can start doing some
pre-processing which is not something
difficult in this data set we just
basically reshape it in a format that we
can pass it to tensorflow whether we are
using here it's the data set yeah the
data set a class of tensorflow in order
to create tensor flow data sets it's so
quite efficient and it creates the Baths
of a particularly bad size and
selflessly images in a quite efficient
way there are also tensor flow has also
different functions but this one it's a
very recent so we can run this and we go
yeah with so simple pre-processing we
can go to the interesting part of our
[Music]
hands-on session which is we start
defining variational auto encoder model
which is going to be an extension of of
Karis model the class of Karis model in
order to initialize that class we will
have the
encoder and the decoder there someone
can have different implementations but
what I think it's nice to see it's how
the someone can implement the encode and
the sampling part so for the encode part
you can see it here it takes
the encoded encoded input image and it
returns back distribution of weight the
mean and the standard deviation of a
particular distribution and then a
function the parametrized what it does
it's samples from that distribution
taking as input the that mean and
variance actually for in order to train
over this particular variation a little
colder more stably we use a log variance
instead of standard deviation or
variance but it's exactly the same ideas
as present before now I we have just to
use the exponential of the local
variance in order to some other
distribution and then we can have a
function to reconstruct the image which
takes the input of the encoder and calls
yeah that accounting function so that's
a way how we can call different
functions of our variational not a coder
and yeah and of course computing our
loss function what we said it's that the
loss function it's has two components
the reconstruction loss which tries to
capital using here is when square error
tries to reconstruct the input image in
very good way and it has also the Latin
gloss that KL lost with what it tries to
do it's to penalize distribution some
decoder that they are very different
from the standard normal distribution so
we call the encoding part we sample from
that we decode and then we computed a
lose function and of course someone that
needs to run back propagation as the
normal neural networks and yeah we need
some ways to compute the gradients etc
it's like normal back propagation and
the way that the reason that it's a
normal back up propagation even though
we have this probabilistic aspect of it
it's something that is called the
parameterization tree I explained this
on the notebook but yeah I don't think
we have a lot of time to go through it I
also have a source it's a way that we
sample from the encoder they what we say
the encoder is for its point returns I
mean a distribution basically so the way
that this works
it's that instead of considering that we
have a layer that it's like a
probabilistic layer with distributions
of for the different inputs that we have
we consider that we sample from those
distributions and we have a kind of
fixed effects the Latin space for for
that particular sampling that we did as
a result basically our Latin space it's
a function of the mean and the
covariance matrix here the standard
deviation variance whatever and someone
can compute
partial derivatives of them and going
and compute and drink normal back
propagation if someone is interested in
that and I explained the variation
allows for those of you who are not
familiar with convolutional neural
networks even though we had a session in
the morning I would like to have I have
some live images here I have that I can
remind you what is this you are familiar
with convolutional neural networks all
right I expect so and so what we need in
the autoencoders that it's different in
order to the decoder part to increase
the image in the Latin space
representation into the original input
dimensions so that we have the
reconstructed image its transpose
convolution layers as well which called
to the convolutions and here we define
the actual architecture of our neural
network so what we do for the encoder
its yeah we have the input layers just
to convolutional neural networks then we
flatten the input and yeah we have
another dense layer and for the decoder
will do exactly the opposite process we
take advance we get basically the result
from the encoder through a dense layer
and then just two convolutional the
convolutional neural layers in that case
and yeah we can create and model the
same way oops I didn't run it the single
a single way
okay trans should be able to any
transistor on and see yeah
and we create the model we can see for
example the summary of the model what I
described into the number of parameters
that it has and we go to training the
model in order to plot the
reconstructions there is some kind of a
trivial plotting function here and we
can proceed and actually train our
neural network and I train it here for
50 X so that we can see the results we
can see if you train it how they your
original data looks like how your
reconstructed images look like I think
yeah I have to make it smaller so that
you see it later
and you can say that for its iBook how
are the results they are being improved
for that until the last row what we see
some generating samples which we are
doing it with just sampling the Latins
face we take random samples err and - we
see what kind of images we can get from
it
so we see indeed even though it's l48 a
box we see that indeed the various
knowledge recorders produce blurry
images it's something it's for the
generating images for that now look it's
completely random but but you can do it
around a specific distribution and you
can yeah
guide your sampling process to what you
prefer it's for this one it's just
exactly it's being returned back and
then you take the average of them but
what someone can do and I would like
also to say for that if we have the time
during that session it's that you can
separate them or add weights to them and
having so do use that weight as a hyper
parameter and optimize it so it depends
on how someone who wants to reconstruct
good images and basically have go to
different ization properties if we see
it like this and this is a hub
hyperparameters you can see for the
moment ago for this demo as it is now we
can consider that it's 50/50 it's a zero
point yes you can you can see that where
I compute the reconstruction losses
I did service um
and for example another thing that yeah
that I have here someone basically can
use just the reconstruction and law loss
completely and say that it's the returns
the results enter presentations exactly
as the normal other coders it takes some
time
and then whether we are going to do it's
basically to visualize our Latin space
to see how it looks like for those
images and try to do something like what
Ruben also was suggesting that we try to
go to direct our data generation process
to go through particular directions
basically something that looks a lot
more like pullover or something that
looks more like ankle boot etc
seven Morra it works to go and I will go
through the rest of it first
interesting because we have a random
sample is here what we can say it's so
many much they look from the randomly
sample space they look something in
between for example trousers and two
dresses you can say that it goes with
weight so let's try to see basically how
the Latin space of the training images
looks like and we see yeah what exactly
we were expecting and if we want to see
for example some interesting patterns
here we see for example that uncle boots
sneakers and sandals they are all
together in a similar area why for
example t-shirts and shirts they are on
a similar area as well we can try to
visualize it with other dimensionality
reduction techniques like you map for
example which says release state of the
art and are doing visualizations in
two-dimensional space but of course it
cannot be used for data generation just
for us to see how our auto encoder
worked for two-dimensional
representation and - we will see
basically that with clustering it's
quite similar but more well separated
something that was expecting for very
low dimensional technique and basically
how to generate and to take some time
I will explain the rest of the notebook
so that till you Muppets are running so
that we can finish and hand it over to
Sonali and cool
so what another thing that we can do its
yeah we can generate images like random
random sampling or generating images by
creating a grid and saying how this
works
all we can direct the process okay we
got how yeah they must look like it's
yeah quick and say that it's a kind of a
similar representation so these certain
certs they are still here again together
which means that I have the images they
cannot be separated very well so that
also why we say it in the Latin spice of
various non low tech order
overlapping so we can get by comparing
those two visualizations and evaluation
of our Latin space from the encoder
because this you map visualization it's
really optimized in order to this to to
this two-dimensional representation and
going again to generating some images
from a great week and see how our images
they change basically from the grid from
pull over to trousers for example or
here I think it's from bug to pull over
and so on or what we can do it's a
weekend oops
yeah because it needs to be anyway this
is text and to another thing we can do
it's on our Latin space we can basically
find which is the average position of
address or the average position of Apple
or we can create also vector that goes
from a towards the direction of blubber
and generate images thereby adding
different weight on the positions on
that Latin space and we see something
that starts like a dress moralist and
two goes towards the direction of lover
with different of whites on that
I'm already over time so I would like to
hand it to Cunha and Sonali you can play
with the notebook do you have any other
questions so let's go to rich text
generation
Oh
hello hello is it on hello everyone so
I'm good and together with Sonali we're
doing an internship here focused on
generative artificial intelligence and
we're going to tell you something about
a basic way to generate sequences of
text so I'm gonna start with a question
how many of you know about current
neural networks I assume you know about
it alright cool so we're gonna use of
current neural networks to generate text
and I don't know if you guys know the
name of this conference it's the animal
meeting of Association for computational
linguistics and it's a conference that
focuses on natural language processing
and as you can see it's gaining in a lot
of popularity the last few years and
with this popularity also comes text
generation which is really interesting
topic because there's a lot of
applications for text generation you
could do text summarization you can
write an annual report based on all your
financial financial values you can
create a Twitter bot there's actually
really funny example of this which is
not working anymore it's not producing
tweets anymore but it's called deep drum
and they basically trained a model on
drums tweets and you can look it up it's
funny it's really funny and another
thing that they're doing in green owes
about as well is conversational
marketing and you can use generate API
in this field as well so when we're
working with text text is kind of
sequential data so you have words
following up each other and it's a
sequence of data points and some data is
you need to keep in mind that if you're
writing a text the next word is based on
the words that come before so you need
to have that information
in your and your system and to make text
computer readable we need to convert it
into numbers because when you create a
model it takes numbers as an input if
you put in text not much it's going to
happen so that's also something we do in
a notebook which you'll see in a few
minutes so let's start off with
recurrent neural networks for those of
you that don't know it so I think all of
you are familiar with neural networks
right alright so you have an input here
this is a direct dot it goes into the
into the record nola or block now what
happens is it gives an output it
predicts what is the next part of the
sequence and what it additionally does
is that the output is also serving as a
input to the next time step so you got
an output here which is the output of
the model and then in the next time step
you put the same output in the model
again so it can keep this information in
account when generating the next part of
the sequence and so it's one block but
if you unroll the block it looks like
this so over here you have times that
one times two times R 3 and so on so
it's the same block but it just gets
currently activated with the new
information in mind and after you have
the output it goes in a softmax function
which basically assigns a probability to
all the words in the vocabulary and then
you get this probability is weight
against the ground truth so you have an
input word and in the data there's a
next word in the sequence but your
network also predicts an X word in the
sequence or it takes a vector of
probabilities and then this probability
vector is compared to the ground through
and based on this there is
backpropagation and there's a it's a
specific kind of back propagation back
propagated with time it works a little
bit different than normal back
propagation but we won't go into that so
you can look that up if you are
interested in that and well the exciting
part of this workshop is of course
generating the text with an RNA and the
way we do that is we train our model and
the model learns to predict what is the
next word in the sequence and what we do
then is the the word that it has
predicted the factor of all the
probabilities we sample a work from that
and there's multiple ways you can do it
you can just pick the work with the
highest probability what you get is a
very predictable algorithm that just fix
the most probable work so you're gonna
have the same output for some certain
input but that's quite boring so we do
is random sampling so you have this
factor of all the probabilities and then
you just randomly sample one of the
words and the words that have a higher
probability of being the next word in
the sequence also have a high
probability of being sampled and you can
control this by adding temperature which
is a type of parameter that determines
how high if you have a high probability
the probability of that work also gets
raised so it's higher our chance of
picking that word and if you have a low
a very high temperature if you have very
low temperature if that happens if you
vary as a very high temperature then the
model basically upgrades the probability
of high probabilities already so what
happens then is that the model becomes
more predictable we didn't want that so
we set the temperature a little bit
lower so it becomes less predictable and
you get more interesting outputs so
that's what's happens here at the top
step and I'm that output
the model creates generates is also an
app and input to the next time step and
then the same process happens again you
got a new word and then in the end
for example user input could be food and
then the model generates is an is a new
input vary and so on and then it
generates a sentence over here or maybe
multiple sentences based on how long you
want your sequence to be and then you
have I generated piece of text so that's
how the is a question yes that's
basically at us
so the temperature determines that if
you you have this pack of probabilities
and the temperature basically gives a
higher value to high probabilities so it
even increases them more and it gives a
lower value to probably already low if
you have a high temperature so if you
have a lower temperature the words
become more random because you get more
cramped and then a word that would be
very random that's how a probability so
there's a higher chance of picking that
word instead of having no high
temperature so that's basically useful
you can play around with it and see what
happens if you have a high temperature
if you have a low temperature yeah
we'll finish with that theory part first
and then going to the workshop so
there's a problem with our Nance and
that is that there's long term
dependencies in text and since on our
own and has no way of remembering
something that was way in the past we
need to figure out how to do that
there's a really nice visualization here
of how that works so the part that is
remembered is on the left and this
basically goes through time and as you
can see the more you go to time the more
information of the input layer is wasted
of the first time step so it gets less
and less relevant and that's something
we can solve with LSD amps long
short-term memories I don't know does
how many of you know what LSD M's are
and how they work okay that's so few of
you I don't know how much time we have
ok so first at the basic are none block
and I'm gonna go through it quite fast
you can go back to the slides if you
want to get a better explanation because
you have a really extensive piece of
text accommodating with every picture
but what happens is this part is the
basic or an envelope and the lsdm part
is basically this whole piece so what
happens is you have to forget gate and
what Elysium does it remembers a word or
some words that were in the past so
using the Frog a gate it tells itself
which words to forget for the next input
word so if you are remembering offer for
example and a new verb comes up it's
it's useful to forget the old verb
because you have a new verb to work with
that's what this gate does
that's the second gate it's called the
update gate and that basically says oh
wait this new value is very interesting
we need to remember it and it gets
pushed towards the cell memory which is
the top part so we first forget the
information we need to forget and then
it updates and adds the information we
need to keep so the new verb so then it
gets updated and then we get to the
output gate and what happens here is
that the input gets evaluated together
with the old output of the prior LGM
block and the l'amore state over here
gets added as a as another way to look
at the earlier dependencies so now you
have the information that you needed to
remember it gets collected and it gets
used in the prediction of the next
output and over here the cell state goes
to the next lsdm lock and the new output
goes to the next sem work as well as a
new input and over there on the top you
see the output so that would be our
prediction this is some fertile reading
you can check the slides later they are
also in the Gipper
get up this is a tension transformer
models I don't know if you guys are
familiar with it but that's basically
the it's becoming the state of the art
now GPT - if that's it tells you
something that's also based on the
tension and it's very interesting but
will not go into that now because that's
a little bit too much for one workshop
and then we can go to the work so thank
you and that's something that Sonali
Lola
does it work yeah perfectly so I'll ask
you to go back to dimitra's guitar and
if you go to the text generation part
yeah you can open the notebook that says
Shakespeare PI data because we're going
to work with Shakespeare text we have
another notebook that is based on
Sherlock Holmes data set which has a lot
of stories but it's more like a homework
for you so when you go home you can
check that out so open it in colon and
if you have any questions during the
whole workshop let me know and I'm going
to go through it quick because we don't
have a good time oh yeah it's a sighs
fine or should I increase it yeah okay
so the first thing you want to do is
mount your Google Drive
yeah the it'll be the mount your Google
Drive just in case if you want to save
some checkpoints or save some files so
that what it does is basically link your
collab to your Google Drive
and make sure that all of yours runtime
is on GPO like we did before with
dimitra's notebook yeah okay so these
are some libraries that we're going to
import most of them are carers and
tensorflow back-end numpy and the glob
is basically library to import a lot of
your files we're not going to use it in
this notebook it's going to be in the
next notebook but you can look at it
later and the next step is to clone the
github repository here so that we can
access the data set and the check points
that you've seen before yep
so we open the Shakespeare data the txt
file and we see what some of it looks
like so the goal for this workshop will
be to generate text that is in the style
of Shakespeare if you all know there are
certain vocabulary that Shakespeare use
uses in his death so that's our goal and
the next step is a processing step so
what we do here first
is take the data and these these things
you see the replace commands what you
want to do here is insert white spaces
around punctuation so generally when you
do text generation the common the common
thing to do is just to remove
punctuation but what we want our model
to do is also learn when to generate
punctuation with your data so what we do
is just add space there so that when you
split it based on the right spaces it
also takes the punctuation size token so
it's a very simple step and what story
in words this list does is it takes all
your stories and it creates token so in
this variable you have your entire
stories but in tokens so here you know
the total number of tokens in the story
is this number and the unique words are
14,000 833 so in this tokens are
included all your words and also
punctuation now the next step is to
split this tokens into sequences here
you see a sequence length and this is
the hyper parameter that you can change
and play along with basically this is
the number of words that your model will
look at when it's predicting the next
word so for here we do 10 you can do it
50 hundred it depends what you want it
to be so when our model is going to be
predicted predicting the next word it's
going to look at the last last 10 words
so this is what sequence length
signifies so what we do here is go over
our entire stories and take sequences of
10 plus 1 sequence length plus 1 which
is 11 and make sequences of it so this
is what we're doing here this is for the
benefit of the organization and for
training for creating our data set next
we
yeah so if we use a Karass library
called tokenizer what it basically does
is so what kuhn said before your machine
your model needs numbers not text so
what we do here is give it all your
sequence data which is text and it maps
every unique word or token to an integer
and tokenizer dot text to sequences what
it does is it converts all your lists of
words into tokens so that you can give
it to your model and to see this you can
see this example if you give it a
sentence call you are you are always
resolved rather to die than to famish
this is one of the line taken from
Shakespeare and you can see the
representation of it as took as integers
so each unique world has a unique
integer that represents it and the
vocabulary length here is your number of
words that are in the vocabulary sorry
total is the number of data points you
have and for your training and testing
purposes you want to split it we do a
general split which is 15% test data and
85% training data this is what is
happening is well children and then we
build our RNN model actually when you
were doing this you wanted to build a
very simple model given the time
constraints and it's quite interesting
to see how such a simple model can still
generate text so we have some stacked
layers here and you can look into the
links and see the arguments that it
takes you can play around with the hyper
parameters that are the unit length and
here what we do is just take an
embedding layer which is a form of
dimensional reduction and then we just
stack some simpler names with drop out
do you know do you guys not know what
drop out is yeah for those who don't
know it's basically what it does it
offsets some of your neurons in your
network randomly so that to create
regularization in your model and that
prevents overfitting in the more
so you compile the model with the lowest
cost category to cross entropy and we do
this because we feed the target the
output data set as one hot encoding
vectors that is there's zero when the
class is not there and one for the
classics representing and this is the
summary of the model now are some helper
functions this is just a generator
function that generates yields your x
and y input and output data parallel e
with the model and this is to just
create efficiency this is temperature
sampling that khun was telling you about
before temperature is another hybrid
parameter that you can set we set it
later when we call it and it's basically
sampling randomly your next word and you
give it the logits from the softmax as
an input and you random randomly sample
but on a multinomial distribution and
this is a very trivial function just
when you display your story these are
some checkpoints we create for our model
which is basically early stopping early
stopping is when you want your training
to stop if your trick if your model is
not doing any better and you monitor the
validation accuracy here and model
checkpoint is saving your weights so
that you don't have to train from
scratch every time that's what we're
going to do here we're not going to
train from scratch you can do that if
you want but i'm going to uncomment this
so we can just save a load of safe
checkpoint from before yeah and you can
train it as well but for now we won't do
it because it's the time and now comes
the generation part so there are two
kinds of generation that we're going to
do one is conditional
where you as a as a user input a text
and it's going to generate the
Shakespeare style text based on your
prompt and one is unconditional sampling
and what it does it is
creates a random seed and from that
random seed it's going to generate some
sample so you can play around with this
so I'm going to do does that anybody
have prom for me that I should give it
to the model anybody okay
then I'm going to write something
running
just something very London
so the parameter is your number of words
is 500 and this is the number of words
that you want it to generate and
temperature is the temperature that I
told you about before for the sampling
part so this is the text that it
generated and it's quite random and you
can see that it's in Shakespeare style
and the grammar sometimes makes sense
but it's quite random if you start from
the top and if you go in the bottom the
bottom doesn't relate too much on the
top and this problem will be similar in
L STM's but hopefully it should be much
better way than esteems because it
remembers longer dependencies and when
you go down there is your lsdm model and
you can run it as well
and you can even play around with
unconditional sampling and see what it
generates very randomly
I'm going to do one condition it's
unconditional something
so this is a sample that it generated
unconditionally this is the first letter
that it took for randomly and this is
what came out of it
so the limitations here are that it
doesn't remember a lot what is happening
in the past it just sees the last ten
words but I think that's in that's not
enough if you're writing a story you
want to remember all the story before
but that's computationally very
expensive so if you go to the github
repository there's a lot of further
reading and we encourage you to look
into active attention mechanism and GPT
to models that use a lot of attention
mechanism that occurred this this
problem here and it's quite interesting
and I don't know if you know about GPT
to buy open AI so basically it it
created four sized text generation
models and earlier before they were not
releasing their biggest size because of
fear of fake news and recently a few
weeks back they released their full-size
GPT to model and the results are very
exceptional you can go to talk to
transformer calm and play around with it
so this is what we show I showed you was
a very basic example of what can be done
and if you add attention mechanism to it
and make your model bigger and more
complex it could work even better and
you can play around with this and
there's another notebook that's
Shakespeare that takes the Shakespeare
data which is also in the repository and
you can in your free time play around
with it and change the hyperparameters
change even the model structure and
train and see what happens yep
I don't think there is a rule of thumb
and it's like you said something that
should be a hyper should be part of
hyper parameter tuning which is a
process when you look into the optimal
hyperbole works best so this is what it
should be here it kind of works because
of the way the texts are written its
dialogues so here it kind of works when
you do ten but if you're doing shakes
Sherlock stories which are whole
paragraphs with dialogues and sceneries
that set into it it doesn't work quite
well and I think there you need
attention as well to remember what
happened before and yeah does anybody
have any other questions
no okay well I'll be around if you if
you need something and yeah thank you
[Applause]
[Music]